it was a face-off over who decides the
best interests of children
with covert levels rising greenwich
council advised local schools to move to
online learning
but the council leader was forced to
reverse his advice when the government
threatened legal action so the
government had issued a legal warning to
a school in where
when they tried to do this couldn't you
have seen this coming well i'm deeply
disappointed by the secretary of state's
decision and frankly i don't think it's
perfectly
acceptable to continue to manage this
pandemic entirely from whitehall
when we're seeing different things
happening in different parts of the
country
so greenwich schools now advised to
reopen but some parents said they might
just keep the kids off anyway
when this all of this came out on sunday
i was like i'm not sending back i can't
take the risk
if they'd have made the announcement
sooner that the numbers were going up
i would have kicked him off of school
yeah and i would have quite happily paid
the fine
because i can't afford to get ill
they've got little bubbles and the way
they've
done it at the school so i think they've
done the best they can so so so i think
yeah why not you know
and and for him uh the social
interaction that he misses is really
important like you know
you know otherwise you've got a 50 year
old man to knock about with all danger i
mean well it's not going to go back to
school tomorrow at this point
no no even if they reopen now because
the end of term was
anyway it was going to be on thursday so
it's just uh
it's just silly you know to keep on
changing our ways every two minutes
there's an air of defiance too amongst
head teachers sky news in conjunction
with the worthless
campaign asked 460 head teachers in
england whether they'd be prepared to
defy the government and close their
school
if they thought it was in the best
interests of the safety of staff and
children
71 per cent said yes they would comments
included the government needs to respond
to this rather than set out on a
collision course with schools
safety trump's politics and the
government has shown itself to be
completely out of touch
with what's going on in school and i
despair at what they'll direct us to
next
but more government compliant heads said
i do not think
schools should break the law and we need
to act
together as a nation my first and
fundamental duty is to keep
young people and my colleagues safe if i
don't feel i can
do that i'll shut my school but under
any other circumstance i want to keep it
open
i think the government's response is
probably pretty heavy-handed
i don't think it will play particularly
well but the government's legal threat
to greenwich is aimed at discouraging
other schools and councils from breaking
rank
this is about practicality meeting the
hard wall of principle the council's
thinking that terms nearly over they've
got
more than 300 teachers self-isolating
the infection rates
are rising notably among school-aged
children and many of them in 10 days
time
are going to have lunch with granny but
the government can't allow
one council to defy the principle that
schools must remain open
because where would that lead these
greenwich students believe it would be
disastrous if schools started switching
back to online learning
like we need it right now more than ever
because it's our last year we have a lot
of work to do so it's better that
we take this opportunity to get all the
teaching that we need and all the
resources
we need to do the work that we need to
do lateral flow tests are to be given to
all secondary schools from
january which should reduce the spread
but won't stop the day-to-day
uncertainty
this virus brings to those running our
schools jason farrell sky news